le championnat des pâtés droite au cours
des vingt dernières années mes potes et
moi avons trouvé le moyen de satisfaire
ses besoins de conquête des victoires de
couronnement va jouer pour cent mille
dollars mais le moment tant attendu est
arrivé
le premier défi est une succession
d'épreuves qui comprend un cas cette
pastèque des bulles gonflables nous
constamment taux des fûts de bière à
descendre la traversée des anguilles
électriques questions alors pas de
questions vous êtes prêt à y aller
dites moi un truc qui pensent qu'ils
sont encore y faire prochaine fille
s'est tendu ce sont ces russe ira
désormais sur la piste et qu'elle vous
au revoir à ce poste et l'accepter
je vais sûrement préféré que tu me dises
ya cinq ans tu choisirais tes potes
plutôt plat
on va centrer le trac en coin
hu
c'est pour ça qu'on recommence ses jeux
cd tout qu'on peut faire contre nous à
vie pour ce genre de souvenirs ton
oreille et dans quel état êtes belle
amitié ne s'éteindra jamais
mais si l'une de ces tranches dégâts
[Musique]